new numbers from customs and border
protection revealing a 128 percent surge
in migrant encounters
last month from the same month last year
this comes as five republican senators
are threatening to withhold support from
any spending packages due to a lack of
funding for border security indiana
senator mike braun is among the five
lawmakers he joins us right now from
capitol hill good morning to you senator
good morning steve okay so what are you
guys uh planning to do here
well there are five of us
senator cruz from texas where all the
action is uh
senator rubio from florida a lot
governor desantis has made an issue that
immigration affects all states illegally
when they come across the border senator
lummus from
wyoming and senator lee from utah
very simply this is where the rubber
meets the road out here is when you
stand firm on issues so look at the
context when i was running back in 18
jobs in the economy and the border were
the two big issues and the jobs and the
economy took off with the tax cut and
jobs act and we had the best one in
history and this is a man-made crisis by
a one-man wrecking ball named joe biden
because
he did it
it was trump we're not going to keep
those policies in place we were down
there at the border in march and saw all
the atrocities including the smugglers
heckling at us and that was at about 75
000 illegal crossings it's now about
triple that
fentanyl all the other stuff that comes
in and this is what most people don't
realize it's not only central americans
54 other nationalities were crossing
back
earlier in the year and the smugglers
are getting money off of everybody that
does it it's a disaster and
in this spending bill listen to this
there's not only uh
no money there for the wall or for the
security that the border patrol wants
but they want to appropriate money to
start tearing the wall down yeah i mean
it's craziness well but here's the thing
senator if the dem you would need the
democrats to go along with you they
don't think there's a problem and that's
your problem
well they don't think there's a problem
on a lot of things and there's a litany
of them we don't have time to go through
but
even on like the vaccine mandate i'm
leading on that where you're trying to
force businesses you know to vaccinate
their employees down to 100 employees
when we've been trying to keep them at
their post working
they have not made one decision that has
really been beneficial to the country
and that was shown i think with the
virginia new jersey elections and man we
better go to town with it in 2022 and
2024. let me ask you about uh the
president's buildback better plan you
know that's the next big bill uh
apparently the cbo is going to come out
with a uh an estimate on how much it
actually costs the white house says it
costs nothing we know that's not true
they're going to come out with an
estimate by friday
uh if if it is a an actual number and
not zero i would imagine there are going
to be some moderate democrats are going
to say wait a minute you made it sound
like a zero but it's actually filling
the blank number we're not going to go
for that right now i think that's been
their kind of modus operandi all along
talk about all the benefits of more
government
when we're now nearly 30 trillion in
debt and the cbo
if they do the job that they did back in
the tax cut and jobs act which that
actually was an estimate that they
needed to re-position on because it was
working they need to be honest here and
hopefully there'll be enough moderate
democrats left in the house and i think
uh kirsten cinema has said she's worried
about raising revenues here joe manchin
about spending i hope they're true to
their beliefs because it's a funny
feeling to be in the position we're in
all right senator thank you very much
for taking a little time out of your
morning to be with us
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis